[Music]
all right today's question comes from
hannah
in florida i am 21 married
and a new parent to a son my parents
approached me recently about funding
their retirement because i quote
owe them there's been a lot of damage
done in the past and to be completely
honest i have lost respect for them
well no kidding i'm unsure how to handle
this too and i just met him
yeah i'm uninviting them to my birthday
just on this i'm not sure you mom how to
handle this and where to go with the
relationship
um i think the famous song says get that
dirt off your shoulder
brush it off and move on i don't know
what to say man um you don't owe your
parents retirement
god um yes there's clearly been a lot of
damage done another circling back
for round two round seven yeah
at this point you need to be confident
and strong you've got a new family
and unfortunately um the old saying goes
not by your hand but in your lap
somebody put a grenade in your lap and
you've got to deal with it
and that means you've got to be the
adult in the situation and
i think i think there's a here's how i
approach this dave
she gets the opportunity to demonstrate
how an adult handles problems and so it
could be easy to say i'm gonna block him
never talk to him again
and what that does is it shoves that
problem in a in a box and throws it in
the ocean but
there's it's the problem still there i
think she reaches out
probably in writing and says i'm not
going to do this and by the way
me and my husband have talked about
boundaries and here's how we're moving
forward
um this is so toxic and so gross i don't
even know what to do with it
um but it is what it is and those
parents do exist
um proof you don't have to pass a test
to be a parent right um
because some of you people would flunk
all right now and start again
but um wow i
so yeah pick up henry cloud's book
boundaries honey
uh because you're gonna have to learn to
set them and you're 21 years old
and it's not fair that this is coming at
you
your your parents are weird um
you don't owe them a retirement
and um what you can do is just lovingly
but
very strong say smile
calm no yelling no screaming no cussing
uh just um no we don't owe you a
retirement and no we're not doing that
what we owe you is to love you and we do
that
we love you and we cheer for you and we
hope it works out for you good
we hope you do well and we'll be
cheering for you
and um you know if you're ever hungry
holler
and uh we'll make you a meal you can
come over and hang out as long as you
behave while you're here that's right
but um you don't have to cut them out of
your life you don't have to hold them
back
now i will warn you this okay when
people that don't have good boundaries
i.e your parents okay eg
your parents um people that don't have
good boundaries when you give them
boundaries
they generally don't like it they flip
out so
do not expect this to go like oh darling
i'm sorry i never thought about it that
way
no these are people that are gonna go
you're ungrateful we pay for this
dadgum travel agent for guilt trips
right
and that's what they're going to be so
you know no don't expect anything but
them to go cray-cray on you
and just because something is
uncomfortable or just because something
breaks your heart doesn't mean it's the
wrong thing
expect them to come back and make you
sad to hurt your feelings
to be immature morons and
you still did the right thing because we
kind of have established that they are
that
wow already i'm trying to put myself in
a situation where i would
can you imagine calling rachel and
daniel in it's hey guys listen um
me and your mom this time i bought you
diapers
you owe me i've done the math and
remember that time i fed you you owe me
you remember that time i you know just
whatever
you know did whatever for you like i did
what my parents would do yeah but you
now owe me
i can't wrap my head around that
conversation yeah and it's just
ah man i'm sorry that you're going
through this hands it's heartbreaking
and honey this is not going to be easy
and it's not going to be over quick but
the answer is you don't owe them and you
have to gently and kindly say
no all i owe you is to love you and i
will pay that debt
and she points to it i know this isn't
the first time you've been put in a
situation with him it won't be the last
time that's why
dave's recommendation that book
boundaries practice with you and your
husband y'all come up with some
rules of the road for your new family
and stick to them man
yeah and and then you decide how much
access they have to your kid
because are they going to misbehave
around your kid you know and that's what
you're going to be facing yeah
so it's it's harsh and it's what's
sadness
what's sadness john you have a big
career ahead of your mind hey man
there's a lot of people in america that
need you what